So they bow down to Joseph and properly.
So you know he's,
he is even without his coat,
he's still the person with the coat of many colors.
And Joseph saw his brothers and he knew them,
but he made themselves strange and to them it's a number of years have passed
and he spoke roughly unto them and he sat down with them,
where do you come from?
And they said from the land of Canaan to buy food.
And Joseph knew whose brothers were,
but they didn't know who he was.
And they came back to Jacob their father and told him all that be fail them and
said,
the man who is lord of the country spoke roughly to us and took us for spies.
And we said to him,
we're,
we're true man.
Honest man were not spies.
We be 12 brothers sons of our fathers,
one is not.
And the youngest is this day with our father in the land of Canaan.
And the man said,
here's how I'll know that you're honest man.
Leave one of the brothers here with me and take some food for the famine of your
households and be gone,
and then bring your youngest brother to me,
then I'll know that you're not spies,
but that you're honest man,
and I'll deliver the other brother and you shale trade in the lounge so you
don't have to starve to death.
And it came to pass as they empty their sacks,
that behold every man's bundle of money was in his sock.
And when both they and their father saw the bundles of money,
they were afraid.
So they had bought food from Joseph and he gave them the food and then he put
all their money back and their socks,
which I could imagine would worry them to some degree.
And Jacob said,
me,
you've already bereaved of my children.
Joseph is not as Seminis.
Not now.
You'll take Benjamin Benjamin away.
All these things are against me.
And Ruben spake unto his father,
saying,
slay my two sons.
If I bring him not to the deliver him into my hand and I will bring him to the
again
and he and he said,
nope,
my son shall not go down with you for his brother is dead and he's left alone.
If mischief befall him,
by the way,
in the which you shall go,
then you shall bring down my gray gray hairs with sorrow to the grave.
Now there's a hand,
see what happens in the last part of the Jacobs stores.
The Joseph story is,
and this is associated with the idea of putting your house in,
order,
your individual house in order,
and then putting your family's house in order.
Let's say it's reversed a little bit in this story because Joseph puts himself
together and then he puts the state of Egypt in order,
which is really quite interesting because Egypt is the canonical tyranny right
in the old testament.
And so the idea is very,
very clear here that the person who wears the coat of many colors can put the
tyranny right?
And then the next extension is,
well he has to put his family right now.
You know,
generally the progression would be put yourself right then put your family right
then put the state right,
something like that.
It doesn't really,
if you could do it in a different order,
that's probably okay too.
But so,
so that's what happens at the end of the story is that,
you know,
Joseph is doing pretty damn well and so is the state that he serves.
But that isn't good enough for him.
He wants his family to be functional and put together properly even though they
did terrible things to him.
And that's very interesting because once someone does terrible things to you,
then the logical thing or a logical thing to think is well go to hell in a hand
basket.
You know,
like you,
you deserve exactly what you get,
but
it's not a very productive attitude,
especially if you're around people that you have to be around.
You know?
So like if it's your family and you go have a family dinner and one of you
punches the other and then the other punches you back.
And then that's like the family dinner for the next 30 years.
It doesn't seem to be very productive.
Even if you're the person who happened to get in the last blow because you're
going to have to put up with them at minimum.
It might be nice to just let what you can go,
go and work to make towards making things better.
You have to get rid of the idea of revenge and resentment and all those things
that you carry along.
But,
but it's probably better to think about how your family could be if it was
really functioning well.
And then just to aim unerringly of that.
I know.
No,
that's not easy.
I mean,
people are very screw in.
There's no end to the depths of pathology within families.
But of course this story states that very clearly,
I mean,
they tried to kill him,
they sold him into slavery.
It's,
it's a pathological family,
let's put it that way.
And,
but Joseph's attitude is,
well,
we got to set this right not least because of his father,
but it isn't only because of his father,
as you see,
as the story unfolds.
And the famine was sore in the land and it came to pass.
When they had eaten up the corn,
which they had brought out of Egypt,
their father said unto them,
go again and bias a little food.
And Judo spake unto him,
saying,
the man did solemnly protest unto us.
You not see.
You will not see my face except your brother be with you.
They cannot go back to Egypt without Benjamin.
And they said,
the man asked his straightly of our state and other kindred saying,
is your father yet alive?
Have you another brother?
And we told them according to the tenor of those words,
could we know that he would say,
bring your brother down.
And Judas said unto Israel,
his father,
send the lab with me and will arise and go that we may live and not die.
Both we and vow and also our little ones,
I will be sure it he for him,
my hand shell,
they'll require him if I bring him,
not under the inset them before the Len.
Let me bear the blame forever.
Well.
So Judah who played a pretty dismal role in the original selling Joseph into
slavery seems to obviously have learned something by this point since he's
willing to put himself on the line,
you know,
to take responsibility for the situation and to put himself on the line and to
stand in for Benjamin.
So he's making himself into a sacrificial object of sorts.
And so
the game that Joseph's playing,
because he sort of teasing his brothers,
but he's also testing them,
the game that he's playing is twofold.
It's one is have you bloody well learned anything or are you just as corrupt and
useless as you were before?
That's game number one.
Then game number two is maybe if I poke and prod you and put you into a
relatively difficult and mysterious situation,
I can get you to clue the hell in and the dog some responsibility and we can
move this whole mess forward.
And so that seems to be happening.
So Judah is taking responsibility.
And Ruben did that as well and the men took presence and they took double money
in their hand and Benjamin and rose up and went down to Egypt and stood before
Joseph.
When Joseph saw Benjamin with them,
he said to the ruler of his house,
bring these men home and slay and make ready food for these men shall dine with
me at noon.
And the men mandate is Joseph Bade in the man brought them in into Joseph's
house.
And when Joseph came home,
they brought him the presence which was in their hand and bowed themselves again
to him,
to the earth.
And he asked them if their welfare and said,
is your father?
Well,
the old man of whom you speak is whom he spake as he yet alive.
And they answered thy servant,
our father isn't good health,
he's yet alive.
And they bowed down their heads and made oh basins.
And he lifted up his eyes and saw his brother Benjamin,
his mother's son,
and said,
is this your younger brother of whom you speak unto me?
And he said,
God,
be gracious unto Thee.
My son.
And Joseph Made Haste for his bowels,
did urine upon his brother,
and he sought where to weep.
And he entered into his chamber and wept there.
And he washed his face and went out and reframed himself and said,
set on the bread.
And they sat before them.
Now he plays another trick on his brother.
So he has them all sit at the table,
but he lines them up according to age.
And so he started up,
what is he trying to do?
He started to freak them out fundamentally and so at,
and he manages that because they have no idea how in the world they could
possibly,
he could possibly pull something like that or if they think it's magic.
And the men marveled at one another and he took and sent messages unto them from
before him,
but Benjamin's mess was five times as much as any of theirs.
So what's he doing?
Well,
he's testing his brothers again,
the fact that when he was the child Joseph,
that he got more meant that his brothers got terribly jealous and then
murderous.
Right?
And so now he's doing the same thing with Benjamin.
He's thinking,
okay,
well I'll give this kid more than his share
and I'll watch how these reprobates behave and see if they've learned anything.
And so,
and he commanded the steward of his house saying,
fill the men,
suck with food as much as they can carry and put every man's money in the sock
as well.
And put my cup,
the Silver Cup in the sax mouth of the youngest and his core and money.
And the steward did according to the word that Joseph had spoken,
as soon as the morning was light,
the men were sent away along with their transportation.
They cop is found in Benjamin sack while,
so Benjamin is Kinda young and
Joseph sends out people to find out where the cup is gone and they find it in
Benjamin's in Benjamin sack and they're very upset about this.
Um,
they said that a harsh punishment would be fall.
Whoever had the cop in his sock,
they rent their clothes and laid at every man his ass and returned to this city.
Judah and his brethren came to Joseph's house for,
he was the out there and they fell before.
I'm on the ground,
very unhappy and apologetic,
and Joseph said unto them,
what feed is this that you have done?
Huh?
Don't you know that a man like I can certainly divine.
I know what's going on.
And Judah said,
what shall we say?
What shall we speak?
Or how could we possibly clear ourselves?
God found out the iniquity of thy servants.
Behold,
we are your servants,
both we and also he with whom the cup is found.
And he said,
God forbid that I should do so,
but the man in whose cup and whose hand to cup is found,
he shall be my servant and has for you get you up in peace to your father.
It's the discovery of the cup.
Judah says,
no.
Therefore,
when I come to the servant,
I father my father and the loud be not with us and seeing that his life is bound
up in the lads life.
It's you'll come to pass when he sees that the loud is not with us,
that he will die and the servants shall bring down the gray hairs of thy
servant,
our father with sorrow to the grave.
For Thy Servant became security for the Latin to my father saying,
if I bring him not unto Thee,
then I shall bear the blame to my father forever.
Now therefore I pray thee.
Let me stay instead of the loud and let the loud go with his brothers for how
shall I go up to my brother and the loud be not with me.
Let's pair adventure.
I shall see the evil that will come on my father.
Okay,
so what's happened?
Well,
they learned their lesson.
So now Judah again is willing to stand in the place of Benjamin and become a
slave himself.
And so now Joseph has determined that his brothers have developed their
character to the point where reconciliation might be possible.
You know,
it says you should forgive and forget,
but the conditions for that are quite,
are quite specific.
You know,
if you're,
if you have a dispute with someone and they've wronged you in some sense and
they apologize,
the question is,
well,
what's the apology?
Well,
it's a layout of a rationale.
It's something like,
as far as I can tell,
here's the reasons I did this horrible thing.
And here's what I've learned from it and here's what I'm going to do to try not
to do it again.
And would you give me another crack at it?
That's the proper repentance,
right?
And then you forgive because you're an idiot too,
and you'll probably do something stupid and maybe you'd like the same kind of
break at some point.
And,
and besides,
if we all held each other completely to account at all possible times for
everything,
then it just be hopeless because there'd be no room for error.
So if forgiveness,
which Joseph has showing his wise forgiveness,
he's not going to put himself out on the line for people who haven't learned so
that the same stupid thing can happen again so that they can continue to spread
misery wherever they go.
He's going to find out if they've clued in a little bit.
And then if so,
then they can move on with putting the family together.
And so that breaks them up.
He says Joseph could not refrain,
refrain himself before all of them that stood by him and he cried.
And then he said,
get every mountain away from me.
So all of the people except for Joseph's brother left and there stood no man
with him while Joseph Made himself known unto his brothers.
And Joseph said,
I'm Joseph is my father is still alive.
And his brothers could not answer for they were troubled at his presence.
Yeah.
Understatement of the decade there.
And Joseph said unto his brothers,
come near to me.
I pray you.
And they came near and he said,
I am Joseph,
your brother,
who you sold into Egypt,
but don't be grieved or angry with yourselves that you sold me hither for God
did send me before you to preserve life.
So now it was not you that sent me here,
but God,
and he's made me a father to Pharaoh and Lord of all his house in a ruler
throughout all the land of Egypt.
Hurry and go to my father and sand to him,
thus say that I son Joseph,
God has made me Lord of all Ge Egypt.
Come down onto me and Terry naught
and now it shall dwell in the land of Gosh and and now shall be near unto me,
Thou and thy children and their children's children and they flocks and herds
and all that.
Thou hast and I there I will nourish you for yet there are five years of famine,
less thou and I household and all that.
Thou has come to poverty,
so that's the other thing that another bit of a hint,
it's a bread hint here.
Who's the,
what's the most reliable source of bread?
Well,
isn't bread itself,
it's whatever it is that gives rise to bread and that's what Joseph is in this
story.
He's the force that gives ride rise to nourishment.
That's an Joseph is often considered a type of Christ,
which means like a precursor in some sense.
That's,
that's one way of thinking about it and you can see that echoed right there.
It's like,
well,
what do you store up for famine?
You store up character.
That's the best way through.
Now,
that doesn't mean you don't also store up bread.
And they went out of Egypt and came into the land of Canaan unto Jacob and told
him Joseph is still alive and he's governor and Jacob's heart fainted for he
didn't believe them.
And they told them all the words of Joseph,
which he said to them.
And when he saw all the wagons,
which Joseph had sent to carry him,
the spirit of Jacob,
their father revived and Israel said,
it is enough,
Joseph,
my son is he had a life.
I will go and see him before I die.
And Israel took his journey with all that he had and came to Beersheba and
offered sacrifices unto the god of his father,
Isaac.
And God spake unto Israel in the visions of the night and said,
Jacob.
And he said,
here am I.
He said,
I am God,
the God of my father.
Don't fear to go to each down into Egypt for I will make you a great nation
there.
And so that's how the Israelites end up in Egypt.
I will go down with the and to Egypt and I will also surely bring the up again
and Jacob shall put his hand upon thy eyes,
denies eyes.
And Jacob Rose up from Beer Sheba and the sons of Israel carried Jacob their
father and the little ones and their wives in the wagons,
which pharaoh had sent to carry him.
So the families now all United in the proper state of being that Joseph has
arranged and they took their cattle and their goods.
It's so interesting too because of course Joseph isn't even,
he's a foreigner as well as being a former slave and prisoner,
foreigner,
slave and prisoner.
And yet he ends up ruling Egypt sheer sheerly because of the force of his
character and competence.
And that's really something to think about.
And they took their cattle because that story there is that there isn't anything
stronger than that.
Doesn't matter what the circumstances are that there isn't a forest that's more
powerful not,
and I don't think that that's naive.
In fact,
I think it's the exact opposite of naive.
No matter where you are,
you can generally make things better.
If that's what you want to do,
and unless you're in in a place that's really hell itself,
not usually is something that elevates you in,
elevates the people around you,
and you can do that wherever you are because there isn't a place that's so small
that you can't do that.
That's the message of the prison.